another night of looting
and what's the media's priority he calls
them
thugs who is the thug here hiding in a
bunker
hiding behind a suit we are teetering on
a dictatorship
is the president declaring war on
americans
what is happening here the president had
been saying incendiary things
certainly if you've been listening with
any kind of open-mindedness certainly
not
helpful things he's all but calling on
authorities to crack skulls at these
protests
is just not something that you normally
see in the united states of america it's
something that you see in
more authoritarian countries
amazing meanwhile the new york times
headline reads america's protests won't
stop
until police brutality does meaning they
hope
this could go on forever one of their
scribes
chides mayor de blasio for being too
pro-police
meanwhile the city burns and stores are
looted cops are beaten and people
are beaten too the new york media by
sticking to their narrative that we
deserve the punishment
reject protecting our citizens they mock
the need for military
intervention people have families and
relatives and they have spouses who work
at night
when our leaders believe this mayhem is
inevitable and perhaps even necessary
then who protects us now still others
blame trump
now i watched the streets of my home
destroyed it wasn't
trump it was criminals who knew that the
light touch
of impotent leaders allows for ruin
and how is it trump's fault that a cop
killed a defenseless man in a liberal
town
held by liberal politicians it's not but
the media says the opposite
it's why when you say everyone's in
agreement over mr floyd including trump
they respond that that's not enough
which tells you again they want no end
to the violence they want to burn it all
down
they being radicals on the street in
faculty lounges and government
and the minority shopkeepers are paying
the price the minority owners of
restaurants are paying the price
minorities in general always pay the
price
the only people who aren't paying any
price are the media
they wax poetic and they rake it in
they hope if they feed the crocodile
enough as churchill once said
it will eat them last it will and then
it'll get food poisoning
so dana um i don't know where to start i
am so depressed
i honestly can't even focus any more on
this
uh they were throwing hammers at my
residential windows
because they can't steal anything
anymore um
and yet we have we have leaders
who are more upset we have the media's
more upset about trump's tweets than the
fact that people are getting beaten
i don't get it well i feel like the
media is
also in many ways reflecting the
local and state officials in some places
so for example in new york it is hard to
imagine
that they seem to be more concerned
about the lawless
and than for the people who actually
obey the law
um the taxpayers i think of think of all
the people that work really hard they
try to do the right thing that's the
majority of people
that is the majority of people then they
did the lockdown
they lost their businesses they lost
their livelihoods they probably many of
them lost their life savings lost their
hope
lost their dreams and
it is i'm sorry that you're uh depressed
because it's it's hard for everybody
who's a fan of yours greg
to see you like this but we know that it
is from the heart and that you are
witnessing something that the it feels
like the city and the nation
is fighting for its life and we need
help in order to
win this fight i believe that we will i
believe we will come out stronger
um i also if i could just mention two
things
one is this notion that the president
was hiding in the bunker
just want to be very clear no president
asks
to go down to the bunker that is a
secret service
decision they come and they tell you sir
you are going to the bunker they
actually had to carry dick cheney
to the bunker because he didn't want to
go after 9 11. though i really hope that
the media stopped saying that the
president was hiding
that wasn't his choice the the secret
service is in charge of protecting the
president that's that choice
the other thing on the on the media that
i just wanted to mention to you is
this caught my eye today so michelle
goldberg is a columnist at the new york
times i
tend to read her because i like to get i
get the perspective
and the headline is she thinks de blasio
should resign
very liberal left wing columnist and i
thought
wow we're on the same page and then i
realize
oh no she wants him to resign because
he's not progressive enough
because he is sided too often with the
police
and if you saw on the daily briefing
today um one of the police officers who
went after cuomo and de blasio saying
um you have no idea what it's like to be
us they do not feel supported
by their local leadership and i'll leave
it there but
it could go on and on you know juan i
know you were
you were in dc i think you were in dc
during 9 11 or
maybe maybe you were in new york i was
in new york um
it seems like this is so much worse
because it's
dozens and dozens of cities and it was
us versus the terrorists
but now it's the terrorists are us
and we can't do anything because they're
they're
they've hijacked a movement and the
movement can't expel them
so that's why we're eating ourselves
alive and i think why the politicians
are so flaccid on this
that's an interesting perspective
obviously we lost a lot of lives in 9 11
so far
thank god in terms of the protest here
it's been
nothing comparable but i wanted to just
join with you in saying
i want to unequivocally condemn the
violence i just think it's
counterproductive even for those of us
who are seeking
some kind of positive social change in
terms of
reckoning and calling for accountability
for police
brutality in this country dr king so
many
others have spoken about how that kind
of violence
does exactly what you said allows
critics to hijack
a virtuous movement and derail it
because you can't build coalitions on
that basis now on the same time greg
i would say that i want to make sure
that there are just as i want penalties
for people who break the law as
protesters
i want there to be penalties for police
who break the law
in terms of their use of brutal tactics
i want to make sure that there are
repercussions
and equal treatment all around because
to me
we have in this country systemic racism
and i know some people don't want to
deal with it don't want to acknowledge
it they want to just get back to normal
and say oh
we don't how can we deal with that how
long will it take to correct but
we need to do it i think we can both
agree
it's harder to be a black man in america
than it is to be a white man in america
and we need to confront
this because it's it's contrary to our
ideals about equality
it depends what black man you're talking
about
but i i agree that there is racism
the problem is if we if we all and like
you said we all agree on it
it doesn't stop the violence it's like
it's like we go okay what
we want you we want to help you what can
we do and and then
the violence still occurs so it that's
why i think that there's another
aspect to this that is way bigger than
race it's something about undoing
society
jesse what are your thoughts well just
to juan's point
one of the ways you can punish police
you know they have union rules these are
police unions
the unions have devised these systems so
a police officer can have 30 complaints
against him
in a couple years and he gets no
discipline
so that's on something that the unions
can figure out how to do
and on the point you just made about
they can't expel
these criminals and domestic terrorists
from their movement
one way to do it is maybe take a
breather on the protests
they had a week it's been hijacked no
one's talking about george floyd anymore
everyone's talking about the reckless
violence and property destruction
if you sit down the rest of the looters
and the criminals
won't have you as the cover to
perpetrate crimes against the country
that's just a suggestion in terms of the
media
i have never seen so many peaceful
protesters
commit so much violence right how many
excuses does the media have to make
for these acts of violence i mean this
is like the guy who says oh
well my girlfriend only cheats on me
when she's drunk and he says that time
and time and again
i mean just break up with her and
the other point is this you know bill de
blasio
he could do something about this juan
condemned it so did de blasio
de blasio runs the police force tell the
police
crack down and then we can all have
enough of it
because i want you to be in a better
mood greg
i it's hard i was just going to ask
dagan if she's interested in buying an
apartment
it's in a really quiet neighborhood now
uh there's no thoughts you know what
you're trying to make but be funny
and i love you but you know what there
is no telling how much the price of that
apartment is going to collapse
with what has gone on in terms of the
lockdown in the city
half of the restaurants probably will
never come back the destruction of jobs
in leisure and hospitality and retail
and then
all of the violence and looting that has
gone on you're going to see
unemployment here that is that could be
an upward of 30 percent for a very long
time
uh but one real quick thing in terms i
wanted to mention that governor cuomo
could do something rather than
laying the hammer down on de blasio and
the police force here in new york
that's actually call out the national
guard troops with their 13
000 at his avail instead he likes to
talk and not act
meanwhile new york burns